[Music]  grammy-nominated singer Halsey opens up  about her painful battle with  endometriosis tomorrow on the doctor's  when I finally got my under mitrice's  diagnosis it was like the relief of  knowing I wasn't making it all up but it  also kind of sucked to know that I was  going to be living with us forever  the disorder affects a woman's  reproductive system the 23 year old  explains the devastating effects it has  had on her own life I was on tour I  found out I was pregnant and before I  could even really figure out what that  meant to me and I was on stage  miscarrying in the middle of my concert  I put my foot down and I got really  aggressive about seeking treatment and  I've surgery a year ago and I feel a lot  better  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]